hey it's he it's samoa and gigi good
and we are going to see your wrapping
fire
hey et's me samoa and gigi good and we
are answering
yo rapid fire question you better work
[ __ ]
effervescent kind
um and
everything
everything um
i would also like to say kind because
that's been a
big thing that my mom has raised me on
as i'm sure yours is
on i would say non-confrontational
very peacemaker um
bimbo bimbo is that an adjective
yes it is now no further questions
oh just one more
okay i have two wow
i love purple i think that's a really
really pretty color like a deep purple
you know
and i also love the color like orange
those much favorite
we share orange orange is definitely my
number one
um i don't know does your favorite color
fluctuate mine does
mine does yes it was black at one time
it was red but now that
i'm in the purple and orange now that's
what i mean very halloweeny yeah it's
very halloween
[Music]
lunch lunch for sure gym was my least
favorite
yeah always one thousand hated gym
having so what did what was the time
they would use um
dress out when you had to go in the
locker room and undress it for the way
everyone's like oh my god you get to see
the boy it's like no
no no i literally put i always
wore my entire outfit that i wore to
school that day with sweatpants and a
sweatshirt
over it always and then i just oh you
didn't even
i didn't even take my shoes off oh just
put the sweatpants on put the sweatshirt
on and i am dressed a coat
my favorite i i had two mine was banned
i loved band clarinet diva was very good
at it
such a nerd and such a nerd and math
i was really good he was really good god
i was i was good [ __ ] i believe i know
how to do it give me a good algebra
problem honey
what does x equal i'll tell you let me
tell you i have failed every year of
math since the seventh grade every year
every year i don't know how i got how
did you leave i don't know how i got in
college i don't
damn hate math i am feeling correct
oh my god mine was madonna so donna was
my first one roboheart
on my 21st birthday so it was not about
me
but um that was my first one in tulsa
oklahoma
the first concert damn mine was in
melanie martinez
are you kidding are you serious madonna
and melanie martinez but i did see
him i saw gaga the same year oh work so
we'll just say that one yeah
the art rave okay
[Music]
my first job i was um a busboy
and a dishwasher at a place called
something's brewing in conway oh it was
a little coffee shop
and i worked there on the saturdays and
sundays and that's how i made my money
oh that's cute little bus boy a little
bus boy
and a button-up chart what were you 16
16 16.
when i was 16 i worked as a cookie
decorator for
a company called jackie's cookies that
is so you yes
that is such a huge job i meant what i
said
oh i already do so this is me using one
meal so
mom would be a good it's the it's i
think it's called the best the great
value brand of chicken
strips that you get over here ralph's
yeah those are the ones i want
and i want to crinkle fry and i would
like my sauces to be a barbecue
and ranch you prefer crinkle fry over
all the rest i do
i love the taco it's a texture thing
texture it's a crunch for me
and for dessert i would like a um
chocolate chip cookie dough from ben and
jerry's oh lovely
oh that's nice i got half fake do you
like that or is that to chocolate
citron too much chocolate okay too much
chocolate i would have to say
i would probably want to eat uh my
mother's staple which is
spaghetti and marinara sauce and texas
toast
a side of caesar salad that just comes
in a bag that you shake
that's it it feels like home tastes like
home
[Music]
i know mine i was a gymnast for a number
of years and it would probably be
gymnastics or tumbling something of the
sort
i don't know probably who takes the
longest to get ready
[Laughter]
that's probably mine that's my olympic
sport putting nails on when they're
assigning the trophies
you're just like hold on like oh now i'm
here let's go this is the little thing
okay this is i do have yours no i'm
still thinking okay go ahead
line it's such a weird question but it's
it makes so much into my head
i think jennifer lewis should play me
fierce um
from youth until whenever i get older i
just feel like she gets it
and she doesn't know the whole time she
doesn't eat a grown woman as a yeah
put a filter over
don't let kanji always use it yes that's
what we need she gets it she's
i feel like that's the one yeah
i would probably want mine to be um i'm
thinking about
which actresses look the most like me i
guess
whenever i was asked this question like
in high school or college i always said
anna hathaway
because she's an oscar winner she's an
oscar winner and i would say i
i people say i look like anna hathaway
sometimes
oh you know what maybe tina fey okay
that would be fun okay or something
completely opposite like danny devito
i would love that
or they could switch roles like one for
tracks and then one that's right
my in-drag is danny davis and my out of
drag is tina fey splash and half away
we're still casting
that's the three people look at you my
happy place is
um home um
being surrounded by people i love that i
care about genuinely that i like
that is my place so here i was going to
say the same
thing these four walls my happy place as
long as i got some hair in these fingers
i'm happy yeah in drag
[Music]
i know yours and you don't mind yeah you
want me to tell you what yours
is yeah what is it it's rupaul telling
you you have the same power out of
traffic
yeah that's the best piece of advice
that
uh pay your taxes
and don't get up
people yeah i have people
and dancing yeah i love to dance
so strange oh yes i want to dance with
everybody
and i want to travel i want to see the
mother
tucking world absolutely i second that
absolutely
um i just want to feel i want to feel
an audience reaction i haven't been on a
stage with an audience since my season
so i'm ready to
feel what it's like it's amazing
[Music]
you